insurance rises are coming in april and
i think that they will
take the prime minister to task
potentially on that it's obviously
uncomfortable
on the back benches for him as well
because these are the issues now on the
doorstep he promised to level up the
country and in the short term certainly
people are going to be really feeling
the pinch it's going to be a very very
bumpy time for us all in terms of our
own household budgets and it's going to
hurt people and there will be i think
from labour an argument that you're not
doing enough
that's just listening i think the prime
minister is taking to his feet i can
tell the house today that it is my
intention to return on the first day
after the half term recess to present
our strategy for living with kobe
provided the current encouraging trends
in the data continue
it is my expectation that we will be
able to end the last domestic
restrictions including the legal
requirement to self-isolate if you test
positive a full month early mr speaker
mr speaker this morning i had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today
mr speaker the northern ireland protocol
has frustrated business
is undermining the belfast agreement and
is restricting the free movement of
goods
and people within our united kingdom
what action will my right honourable
friend the minister for the union
now take to reunite the united kingdom
and uphold the interests of all
residents including those living in
northern ireland
prime minister my honorable friend is is
quite right because the protocol does
not require uh contrary to the way it is
being applied by our friends it does not
require that all foods and all medicines
and all
plants should be systematically checked
in the way uh that they are mr speaker
and we must fix it and with goodwill and
with common sense i believe we can fix
it mr speaker but if our friends uh
don't show the requisite common sense
then of course we will trigger article
16. we now come to the leader of the
opposition kirsten
thank you mr speaker was the business
secretary right to say that fraud is not
something that people experience in
their day-to-day lives
prime minister
uh mr speaker of course this uh
government and uh this country uh
despises those who defraud people and
that's why we crack down on on forces uh
mr speaker and we've strengthened our
anti-crude task force who are bringing
forward an economic crime bill mr
speaker but we also attach huge
importance to tackling neighborhood
crime and crimes of violence mr speaker
and i'm very pleased that those crimes
are down 17 mr speaker
[Applause]
mr speaker the prime minister's got a
big hole in it
we've had lockdowns for the last two
years
two crimes that people could commit were
online and fraud
and throwing parties as far as i can see
the numbers for both of those have gone
through the roof
but i was asking the prime minister
about the 14 000 cases of fraud a day
many older people duped out of
hard-earned savings
and the business secretary casually
suggests on tv don't worry
it's not real crime
there's a crime going in a manchester mr
speaker nicking cars and shipping them
around the world all financed by covet
loans from the taxpayer
and what's the chancellor's response
write off four billion pounds in losses
and and block an investigation by the
national crime agency
his cabinet turning a blind eye to
scammers
is it
is it any wonder that his anti-fraud
minister realized no one in government
seemed to care and threw in the towel
[Applause]
no mr speaker because what we're doing
is tackling crime across the board and
that's why
we're investing more into in tackling
fraud uh mr speaker but we're also
tackling the neighborhood crime that is
of such massive psychological damage to
people in this country
tackling knife crime uh tackling
burglary tackling crimes of violence in
the street mr speaker with tougher
sentences which they voted against by
the way mr speaker
i'm putting more police out on the
street mr speaker and the reason we're
able to afford it mr speaker is because
we have a strong economy and we're
coming back strongly from kobe and that
is thanks to the big calls that this
government got right
mr speaker his anti-fraud minister quit
saying the failure of government to
tackle fraud was so egregious
that he had to and this is his words
smash some crockery to get people to
take notice
well it seems that the prime minister
hasn't noticed the broken plates and the
shattered glass all around him
it's almost as if he's being completely
distracted for weeks
talking of scams
households are going to have to fork out
an extra 19 billion pounds on their
energy bills
the government is insulting people's
intelligence by pretending it's giving
them a discount
but it's not
it's a con
a buy now pay later scheme a dodgy loan
not a proper plan
he
mr speaker
he shakes his head so let me put this in
language you might understand
when his donors give him cash to fund
his lifestyle and tell him he has to pay
it all back later are they giving him a
loan or a
[Applause]
speaker
discount
our plan
our plan to tackle the cost of living is
faster more efficient and more generous
than anything uh that they have set up
we've lifted we've lifted the living
wage by record amounts we've cut the
we've cut the effective tax for people
on universal credit mr speaker and we're
now setting out a fantastic plan to help
people with the cost of energy mr
speaker and and it is it is more
generous and more effective than more
generous and more effective than
anything labor have set out and the only
reason we can do it's 9.1 billion pounds
mr speaker it's huge sums that we're
using to help people across the country
and the only reason we can afford it mr
speaker is because we have a strong
economy the fastest growing in the g7 as
i think i may have pointed out
to the on to the right of honorable
and
not just last year but this year as well
mr speaker the prime minister clearly
hasn't got the first clue what the
chancellor's signed him up to
so let me help him out his plan is to
hand billions of pounds of taxpayers
cash to energy companies
and then force families to pay it off in
installments for years to come
if it if it sounds like he's forcing
people to take out a loan
and it looks like he's forcing people to
take out a loom isn't it just forcing
people to take out a loan
we are giving people in uh in band
councils have a to d counterparts
houses council tax valuations across the
country that is 27 million homes we're
giving them the equivalent of 150 pound
rebate off their counter their offer is
for 89 pounds mr speaker ours is faster
more generous and more effective and
what they would do and what they would
do and you know this is a global problem
mr speaker caused by the spiking caused
by the spike in gas prices but what they
would do is clobber the the oil and gas
companies right now uh with a yes
with a tax with a tax that would deter
investment in gas just when this country
needs gas mr speaker as we transition to
green fuel it would be totally
ridiculous and it would raise prices for
consumers
mr speaker i was always worried that the
prime minister wasn't one for reading
terms and conditions
he didn't understand what the chancellor
signed him up to and he's just confirmed
my worst fears
there is an alternative or order order
can i just say if you want to carry on
carry on outside i am not having this
perpetual noise coming from the front
bench secretary of state should know
better and i expect better and i
certainly don't need to put up with it
anymore please starman
[Music]
mr speaker there is an alternative he
could stand up to his chancellor tell
him to support families rather than
loading them with debt
tell him to look at those bumper profits
of oil and gas giants shells profits up
14 billion pounds this year bp's profits
up 9.5 billion pounds this year
mr speaker
every second of the day
they've made 750 pounds extra profit
from rising prices at the same time
households are facing an extra 700
pounds a year on their bills
why on earth
is this government forcing loans on
british families when they should be
asking those with an unexpected windfall
to pay a little more to keep household
bills down
the labour plan would global supply it's
an improvement on what do you i thought
he stood for which was nationalizing the
energy companies maybe
maybe he's maybe he's dropped that one
now i can't tell whether he's dropped
that one or not but mr speaker what he
would be doing maybe he has what he
would be doing mr speaker is hitting the
energy companies at precisely the moment
when we need to encourage them to go for
more gas mr speaker because we need to
transition now to cleaner fuels and what
this government is providing is 9.1
billion pounds worth of support it's
more generous than anything labor is
offering and i just repeat my point the
only reason we can do it is because we
kept our economy moving in those hard
times when they took the wrong decisions
and we we came out of lockdown in july
mr speaker when he opposed it last year
and we kept going over christmas and new
year when they opposed it mr speaker and
that's why we have the fastest growing
economy in the g7 not just last year but
this year as well as i never tire of
saying
he can bluff and bluster all he likes
the reality is this
on top of the tory tax rises on top of
the soaring prices the lone shark
chancellor and his unwitting sidekick
have now picked up a buy now pay later
scheme
it leaves taxpayers in debt
while oil and gas companies say they've
got more money than they know what to do
with it's the same old story with this
government get in a mess protect their
mates and ask working people to pick up
the bill
[Music]
[Applause]
but isn't he worried that everyone can
now see that with this prime minister
and this chancellor it's all one big
scam and people across the country are
paying a price
mr speaker what they can see is a
government that is absolutely committed
to doing the right thing for the people
in this country and taking the taking
the tough decisions when labor is
calling for us to take the easy way out
and spend more taxpayers money and mr
speaker it was it was this government
that decided to keep going in july uh
when he wanted uh to stay in lockdown we
kept going over christmas and new year
and by the way mr speaker it occurs to
me uh that we also were able to use
those brexit freedoms to deliver the
fastest and the fastest facts he wrote
yes mr speaker when he not only voted 48
times 48 times to go back into the eu
yes he did but he also voted to stay in
the european medicines agency mr speaker
our plan our plan for jobs is working mr
speaker
we have record low youth unemployment
our plan for the nhs and care is working
mr speaker they have no plan at all mr
speaker our plan for the country is
working we have a great vision mr
speaker to unite and level up across our
country they have no plan whatever mr
speaker and i say to him plan beats no
plan we have a great plan for our
country they play politics
thank you mr speaker the government's 9
billion pound support to help with
rising energy bills is most welcome
but will the prime minister assure the
people of anglesey and beyond that it's
full steam ahead for new nuclear like
wilbur knoweth and that this government
is moving at pace on the future nuclear
enabling fund so that the uk has energy
security jobs and investment right here
on these shores
yes mr speaker i think i was only last
week that i was congratulating her on
maybe this couple weeks on her on her
fantastic advocacy uh for uh for
nuclearnessmon and uh don't forget mr
speaker that labour allowed a nuclear
capacity to decline by 11 on their watch
i don't think maybe you've forgotten
that uh mr speaker uh we want to get
back up there and that's why there will
be at least one big nuclear project this
parliament at least one and our nuclear
financing bill will support that
objective
leader of the smp ian black
thank you mr speaker and i'm sure you
and the entire house will want to join
me in welcoming the remembering several
nitsa campaign that launched their
yearly events in parliament last night
and we almost continued to strive for
ongoing peace in bosnia
mr speaker the flooding of changes in
downing street over the last few days is
a sight to behold it's amazing how much
energy this prime minister can sum up
when it comes to saving his own skin
whilst he's been busy rearranging the
deck chairs in the real world people
continue to be punished by the tory cost
of living crisis
yesterday open democracy found as a
direct result of the chan sellers
national insurance hike
nurses will on average
take a
275 pound year pay cut in april that pay
cut
will hit at the very same moment that
soaring energy bills land bills that
have shot up one thousand pounds in the
space of a year it is a building and the
rest of the public simply can't afford
so rather than the prime minister and
the chancellor scrapping over the tony
leadership will they do something useful
and scrap their regressive hike in
national insurance
mr speaker actually it was interesting
that the general opposition didn't
mention that because i i think everybody
can see how vital this is uh we have to
clear we have to clear our code backlogs
mr speaker we have six million people uh
already on the waiting list i'm afraid
that will that will go up uh and we need
to be recruiting the staff now that's
why we're recruiting fifty thousand more
nurses there are eleven thousand more
this year than there were last year and
to his point mr speaker we've increased
the starting salary uh for nurses by
12.8 percent in addition to the
bursaries and other help that we give
them we value our nurses we love our nhs
and we're paying for it
in blackburn
well actions speak louder than words mr
speaker and if he wants to reward the
nurses today needs to pay them they are
the very backbone of the nationals
health service the very people that he's
hitting with the pay cut in april and i
shouldn't have to remind the prime
minister that at the same time that
those nurses were going into work every
day to fight a pandemic 16 different
parties were happening in his government
the public know what nurses sacrificed
during the pandemic and they know
exactly what this rule-breaking prime
minister and his government were up to
so at the prime minister and his
chancellor seriously telling those
nurses that the reward for seeing us
through the pandemic is a 270 pound wage
cut
mr speaker what we're telling the people
of this country now what fantastic
nurses is we back them all the way and
what they want uh what they want is more
nurses mr speaker that's why there are
record numbers uh in training that's why
we have 11 000 more in the nhs now this
year than there were last year mr
speaker and that and those i think are
fantastic investments in our country and
our society and i must say that i think
it's peculiar that this as i understand
the scottish nationalist party's
approach to health care is now to to cut
off the bottom of doors in schools in
scotland in order to improve ventilation
jen stevenson
thank you mr speaker
as a proud warfarinian i am thrilled
that my city is front and center of the
government's leveling up
getting job seekers of all ages the
skills they need to get into work will
be vital to levelling up in
wolverhampton and city of wolverhampton
college is already doing this at their
brand new facility at bentley bridge in
my constituency
will the prime minister join me in
congratulating the college and also will
he meet with me and my honorable
neighbour and friend um preferably at
wolverhampton college so we can discuss
how more job seekers can get access to
skills and potentially through the city
learning quarter and that final bit of
funding that we need
i i congratulate my honorable friend for
wolverhampton she is a modern truly a
modern-day lady wolfe rooney uh mr
speaker and uh
she's completely right that uh
wolverhampton and the black country were
at the heart of the first industrial
revolution and they're at the heart of
the current uh 21st century green
industrial revolution and i'm very glad
that since uh april 2020 we've seen 125
000 starts to sector-based work academy
program uh partly at least thanks to her
lobbying and her support and wild horses
mr speaker won't keep me away from
wolverhampton
speaker 74 year old janet
had 25 000 pounds stolen by fraudsters
she told the bbc
the money was my mum and dad
i felt i'd let them down
for janet and for the four million
people who fell victim to fraudsters and
online scammers last year fraud is a
crime
so does the prime minister understand
the hurt he and his ministers
cause fraud victims like janet when they
write them out of the crime figures and
dismiss fraud as something people don't
experience in their day-to-day lives
mr speaker
will the prime minister correct the
record on crime figures
and apologize
mr speaker i i direct the house don't
you mr speaker to what i've already uh
said to my old friend the member for for
hartley pool but uh he knows very very
well that this government hates uh fraud
he hates online fraud uh we're tackling
we're tackling the scammers
by helping people to come forward uh
when they get an email when they get uh
duped of course we're helping them in
any way that we can mr speaker but
we are also cutting the crime that
affects people up and down our country
uh
the neighborhood crime
dealing with the county lines drugs
gangs mr speaker and that i think is
something he should support as well and
i'm proud that those numbers have come
down by 17
all right baldwin
thank you mr speaker it's wonderful news
that the first in-person commonwealth
heads of government meeting for four
years will take place during her
majesty's platinum jubilee year
[Music]
can the prime minister ensure that the
global learning crisis is high on their
agenda and will he ask his amazing
diplomats to ensure that every leader in
the commonwealth signs up to the
kenyatta declaration on
education yeah
yeah i i thank her very much thank my
right honourable friend very much
everything she does to support uh
education for for girls i think 12 years
of quality education uh for every girl
in the world is probably the single most
transformative thing we could do uh to
improve uh the world and i remember uh
working with my friend uhuru kenyatta on
the on the declaration and we will
certainly ensure uh that everybody of
the commonwealth signs up to it
hamilton thank you mr speaker mr speaker
at the height of the lockdown
restrictions in 2020 my constituent
who's worked for the nhs for over 30
years was diagnosed with a tumor on her
spine whilst in hospital undergoing
painful surgery her family obeyed the
rules and didn't visit her mr speaker in
the last few minutes a photo has emerged
of the prime minister in downing street
on the 15th of december 2020 surrounded
by alcohol food and people wearing
tinsel it looks a lot like one of the
christmas parties he told us never
happened so for the sake of my
constituents and the sacrifices she made
will the prime minister be referring
this party to the police as it's not one
of the ones already being invested
[Applause]
he's i'm afraid so first of all uh first
of all i'm very sorry about his
constituent and uh for the difficulties
that she's uh she's been through
and i understand i understand uh very
much her feelings mr speaker but in what
he has just said i'm afraid he is
completely in error
[Applause]
thank you uh mr speaker on the 30th of
september 2020 the prime minister joined
me on a building site in dudley on what
is now the new institute of technology
delivering on skills for future jobs and
creating opportunities across the black
country will he join me in
congratulating the delivery team who
delivered on this amazing project
including stakeholders like thomas
dudley and dudley college and will he
actually come and join me in person in
doing so in the nearest opportunity
mr speaker i am uh i thank my honorable
friend he is a great champion for dudley
and for the black country uh mr speaker
and i'm delighted to hear that the black
country and marches institute of
technology is now open and i will
certainly keep his his kind invitation
in mind
paisley
thank you mr speaker prime minister the
film belfast contains the immortal words
if you're
not
listening you probably don't understand
us and if you don't understand us you're
probably not listening
the fact of the matter is that the
protocol has zero support from unionists
the fact of the matter is i hope the
prime minister is listening to this that
in a divided society a solution that
only attracts the support of one section
of that community
will never stand for example will the
prime minister therefore take the
opportunity
to speak to the irish government whose
ambassador daniel mulhern is running
around washington
demanding mull hall running around
washington demanding demanding further
implementation of the protocol on the
basis that it will bring further checks
upon the people of northern ireland does
the prime minister accept that he has
now the responsibility to bring forward
a solution that unites the people of
northern ireland and bring forth a
solution that saves the union that has
been undermined by it
yes mr speaker well i agree with him
completely that there must be a solution
that commands cross community support
and at the moment mr speaker there is no
doubt that the balance of the good
friday agreement is being upset by the
way the protocol is being operated and
we need to fix it mr speaker and that's
what we're going to do and if our
friends won't agree then of course we
will as i said uh earlier on of course
we will implement article 16.
jeffrey clifton
thank you mr speaker rather than a
compulsory windfall tax so favored by
the opposition would my right honourable
friend take an alternative view
summon a high level meeting with the oil
and gas companies with the aim of a
voluntary agreement to bring more oil
and gas onto the wholesale market to
reduce oil and gas prices to help
hard-pressed people deal with the cost
of living problems
uh well mr speaker i would welcome i
thank my well normal friend very much
for that uh suggestion which i think is
an interesting one an ingenious one uh
the oil and gas companies uh create
hundreds of thousands of jobs in in the
uk and uh they're very very important to
our economy uh i will do what i can uh
to
to take forward his request for a
meeting with them but i just remind him
i remind the house that we've frozen
fueled duty mr speaker uh 12 years in a
row are saving people 15 pounds in the
in their cost of filling up their tanks
compared to 2010.
thank you mr speaker i understand the
prime minister has been heard singing i
will survive in recent days
i would suggest that he would be better
off singing careless whisper instead
because mr speaker in 2017 nazim zagari
radcliffe was condemned to an extended
prison sentence in iran because of the
careless words of this prime minister
now in 2022 this week my friend the
leader of the opposition was hounded by
thugs outside this parliament because of
the careless disgraceful words of this
prime minister
so will the prime minister do this
his words repent and resign
mr speaker i i don't think that she
should either
let the thugs and yobs who uh bullied
and uh harassed the right honourable
gentleman off the hook
any more because they are culpable any
more than she should let the iranian
government off the hook mr speaker
because they are culpable
uh thank you uh thank you very much mr
speaker
uh since 2017 referrals for children's
mental health has gone up by a 60 eating
disorders amongst young girls have gone
up by
400 since lockdown and we know that
social media companies play a huge part
in this given that social media
platforms like tick tock are providing
crack for kids in terms of adult content
negative imagery and addictive
algorithms
will my right honourable friend consider
implementing a two percent levy on
social media companies which would raise
a hundred million to fund mental health
resilience programs for children yeah
yeah yeah
mr speaker i know my right honourable
friend has campaigned on this issue uh
assiduously and he's quite right about
the psychological uh damage that social
media can do and i've heard what he's
had to say recently about
tock we will see what we can do to
address all these issues in the
forthcoming online harms bill i'll show
off thank you mr speaker mr speaker
radford is uk's youngest city and has
the 10th largest city economy with a gdp
of 11.6 billion and is bidding to be the
capital of culture now it comes out that
no detailed analysis of the long-term
economic benefits of investing in
bradford and the north through the
integrated real plant was carried out
this government failure has robbed
bradford of 30 billion worth of growth
over the next 10 years when is the prime
minister going to match action to
rhetoric and on leveling up and give
bradford the investment it deserves
prime minister mr speaker i'm afraid
that uh uh where she's she's wrong in
what she says because we're not only
investing massively in in yorkshire uh
through investing in police in yorkshire
640 more uh police investing in
education but she's misunderstood what
we said at the time of the 96 billion
pound integrated rail plan because what
we are saying is that we are we will
look at ways in which we can ensure that
we protract the the eastern leg of
high-speed rail uh
from north of birmingham on the eastern
leg to bradford what we're not doing is
what we're not doing is coming up with a
scheme before we've decided exactly what
to do and how to fund it but we are not
ruling it out mr speaker anderson
mr speaker yeah
yeah yeah
i serve my country with pride in the
royal green jackets
i will always be a rifleman and a
veteran and i welcome the veterans
strategy the prime minister has just
brought out but i asked the prime
minister if veterans will always be at
the heart of this government strategy
and everything can be done to see they
always get what they need and are
honored
yes mr speaker that's why we set up an
office for for veterans that's why
we've ensured that veterans uh get
preferential treatment on uh public
transport one of the first things i did
uh when i became prime minister mr
speaker
and it's why we make sure that veterans
receive us receive for particular
support and encouragement in employment
we encourage employers to take on
veterans as well
thank you mr speaker in the panic
downing street staffing reshuffle at the
weekend the prime minister appointed to
a senior role a man who recently lobbied
the government on behalf of huawei
technologies a hostile state vendor that
this house legislated to exclude
entirely from our country's 5g networks
given the number 10 director of
communications has by definition access
to some of the most sensitive government
information can the prime minister tell
the house whether mr harry's present
role requires enhanced developed vetting
and strap clearance
and whether he has gone through the
necessary checks to provide for that
level of clearance before he took up his
post
[Music]
[Applause]
a curious question that to come from uh
the benches that contained someone who
took i think 586 000 pounds from the
chinese government to support his office
but mr speaker what i could what i could
what i can tell that what i can tell him
is that
this government took the brave and
necessary step of making sure that we
excluded we excluded uh huawei from our
critical national infrastructure and
that mr speaker was the right thing to
do whatever he's saying
[Music]
thank you very much uh mr speaker can i
ask the prime minister a question about
sue gray's
report i asked him well colleagues may
grow i'm only asking this question
because i asked the prime minister last
week and i didn't get a straight answer
it's important it's important because
it's about those who make the law
obeying the law the prime minister the
prime minister wants to be judged on the
fact and that's right
so can i ask him to commit at the
dispatch box that upon conclusion of the
metropolitan police investigation
will he ensure that sue gray's final
report is published immediately and in
full
prime minister mr speaker of greatest
respect to my right or friend i do
believe i answered that last month but
like
or whenever it was possibly last
wednesday as well but i'll repeat for
the benefit of the house that as soon as
all the uh inquiries are concluded i
will immediately publish info whatever
sue grey gives me
thank you mr speaker i understand that
the uk government signed an agreement
with the iranian authorities last summer
that would have resulted in the payment
of the 400 million pounds that we are
we're on and the release of my
constituent nazine zagari radcliffe that
agreement fell through and the debt
still hasn't been paid mr speaker this
case urgently needs the prime minister's
attention and personal intervention so
could i ask the prime minister will he
meet personally with me and with richard
radcliffe i don't want to meet his
colleagues i want to meet with him
personally to find out why the agreement
fell through and why that means zagari
radcliffe still isn't home after six
long years
i thank her very much i thank her also
by the way for all the hard work she
does on behalf of nazanin we remain
committed to securing the release of
nazanin and all the very difficult
consular cases that we have uh in iran
uh she knows the ims debt is uh is
difficult to uh to settle and to square
away for all sorts of uh of reasons to
do with sanctions uh but we will
continue to work on it and i will
certainly make sure uh that we have
another meeting with uh with richard
ratcliffe in due course
natalie
mr speaker
dover is once again beset by miles of
traffic jams along the motorways
affecting residents and local businesses
alike
not because of brexit
but because of brussels bureaucracy
well my right honourable fan the prime
minister meet with me to discuss how we
can invest in our local roads in the m2
in the m20 and the dover tap to unclog
that roads once and for all and also to
get rid of the unnecessary red tape for
a trading global britain
minister
uh yes mr speaker she's absolutely right
in what she uh she what she says as the
economy rebounds and we're seeing all
sorts of pressures but we but we do need
to make sure that we clear uh
bottlenecks everywhere in our system and
that's what we'll do
gerald jones
thank you mr speaker i'd like to refer
to the promised answer to my honourable
friend member for leeds northeast the
photograph referred to is all over
social media everybody can see the photo
the prime minister is in the photo so
can i ask him again will he refer to the
matter to the police because this is not
one of the parties already being
investigated by the metropolitan police
that's precisely the point mr speaker uh
it already has been uh it already has
been that that event already has been
submitted for investigation
that ends prime minister's questions
i'll let people leave before we start
the uq
all right
uh they're just doing a bit of a
changing regard because we're expecting
an urgent question from andrew mitchell
um on afghanistan once the foreign
secretary um in the uk to give a
response to this current situation in
afghanistan uh while we're doing that
and while they're all getting ready just
a quick couple of thoughts from beth
rigby who's here with me in the studio
and tsukisharma really went on on energy
bills didn't the energy bills and fraud
he did and what was interesting about
that was he tried to bind the chancellor
to some of the cost of living crisis
perhaps with an eye on the fact that
rishi sanak is the biggest threat in
terms of the succession potentially to
boris johnson calling him the lone shark
chancellor now richard senate's closely
identified with the farlow scheme so
anyway sorry listen andrew mitchell
let's listen to the humanitarian crisis
in afghanistan
minister thank you mr speaker the
humanitarian situation in afghanistan
remains deeply concerning
in january the un requested nearly 4.5
billion dollars for 2022 the largest
humanitarian appeal on record the un has
announced it will be holding an
international pledging conference
on on the 31st of march and the uk is
strongly supportive of this conference
on the 28th of january 2022 the foreign
secretary announced 97 million of
humanitarian assistance to afghanistan
from the uk
this latest allocation of vital support
delivers the prime minister promised to
double aid to afghanistan to
286 million pounds by the end of january
2022 we dispersed over 176 million
pounds in aid and will disperse the
remainder by the end of this financial
year by the end of march
uk aid allocated since october is
supporting over 60 hospitals providing
health services for over 300 million
people ensuring
4.47 million people get emergency food
assistance through the world food
programme and will provide 6.1 million
people with emergency health water
protection shelter and food through the
un afghanistan humanitarian fund
in addition to providing immediate
assistance for playing a leading role in
international efforts to address
multiple causes of the crisis
the provision of basic services such as
health and education remains critical we
continue to explore solutions for
service deliverer delivery such as
payment of frontline delivery workers
and we're working closely on monitoring
afghanistan's economy economy and
specifically as lack of liquidity and
working with partners to seek solutions
the uk also played a key role in
pressing for a resolution establishing a
humanitarian exemption under the un
afghanistan sanctions regime and on the
27th of january this year the uk
government laid legislation to implement
the un security council resolution
2615 this will save lives and reduce the
impediments faced by humanitarian
agencies
go back to andrew
thank you mr speaker for granting this
urgent question and thank you to the
minister for her response
the stark reality is that britain can
and must do more to rise to this
horrific challenge the inescapable facts
are that the taliban won and we lost but
we had previously promised that the
military withdrawal would not be
followed by economic and political
withdrawal indeed in 2010 when we
announced the end of the combat role for
british troops we doubled agent
development spending from the uk as we
had promised
now while the 286 million pounds pledged
recently is extremely welcome it is
still not clear over what period it is
all being spent and whether it is new
and additional funding
it is however clear that it is not
enough the tremendous response to the
disaster and emergency committees appeal
for afghanistan in december shows too
that the british people do not think it
is enough as once again ordinary
citizens across britain have responded
magnificently
the appalling reports from brave
journalists like christina lam cannot be
read mr speaker without tears of anguish
of the plight of our fellow human beings
selling their daughters into early
marriage to provide food for their
families partying with body organs to
feed their family that isn't this is not
science fiction mr speaker these are
facts attested to by british journalists
and charities working on the ground
while the world food programme is trying
desperately to feed 20 million starving
people mr speaker 90 percent of the
people in afghanistan do not have enough
to eat 5 million are living in camps 4
million are just over the border in iran
and they won't stay there mr speaker
they will be heading for europe and for
britain before long
um professionals have made clear that
4.4 billion dollars is required and
typically fair burden sharing would mean
the uk would agree to do around ten
percent of this mr speaker why is the uk
not hosting this important and welcome
pledging conference in march before the
prime minister decided mr speaker to
vaporize differed there were dedicated
officials steeped in the practicalities
respected across the world who were able
to bring together the necessary
technical skills connections and
experience to lead the international
community to a better and more
responsible place as britain's
international development secretary i
spent half my time mr speaker urging
pleading and cajoling my counterparts in
the rich world to step up to the plate
britain led and the international
community followed we need the same
oomph the same vigor from britain today
to make this happen it's not just an
appeal to our humanity mr speaker it's
firmly and completely in our own
national interest
minister
mr speaker um my right honourable friend
is is absolutely right about the
generosity of the bush people in
responding to this very serious um
humanitarian crisis it is a
deeply tragic situation but the uk
government has also
responded and shown leadership across
the world the 286 million that we have
promised will be spent by the end of
this financial year it has been spent
continually over this period and will be
spent by the 31st of march and that is
the date at which the un is going to be
hosting uh their new donor conference
and the uk uk is absolutely supportive
of this un initiative it is vital that
all countries come together through the
u.n to step up to the marks it's also
thanks to uk leadership that the uk
security council backed uh the
resolution that we had suggested to
enable the delivery of the urgently
needed humanitarian aid whilst
preserving sanctions against the leading
taliban figures and that means that the
humanitarian aid can continue to flow
and won't uh be held back because of
those sanctions um we're also uh working
out to encourage the world bank as i
just said last month to urgently
repurpose the afghanistan reconstruction
trust fund which will not unlock another
1.5 billion dollars and indeed i had
discussions with my officials on it just
this morning
welcome to the shadow foreign secretary
david
uh well we'll step away from the commons
uh just now andrew mitchell putting in a
heartfelt urgent question about the
situation in afghanistan talking about
the dire situation on the ground of
course we on sky news uh had a really
disturbing report that we broadcast
yesterday from our correspondent alex
crawford about
families having to sell their daughters
in order to buy food he referred there
to christina lam who's also reported on
that story and on people selling body
parts in afghanistan
the government arguing that it is doing
all it can
let's bring back in between the
political editor who's here um
beth you know that that is a subject
which has horrified a lot of people this
week hasn't it but um
let's return to prime minister's
questions um
the real
thruster of what kierstama put the prime
minister on the spot was about
fuel bills about the cost of living
about fraud yeah
exactly i mean i think there's two parts
of this pmq's there's policy and
politics so let's start off with the
policy that was all around kierstarma
honing in on some fraud taxpayers money
being wasted uh over the covered years
where people were
committing fraud in terms of government
schemes and some of the billions of
pounds that were lost of taxpayers money
he then went on to talk about the help
that the government has proposed
around fuel bills which could go up by
700 pounds this year for families and
that doesn't include your inflation uh
target or or sorry prediction of
inflation could go up to 7.2
in the spring uh that will have a clear
effect on all of our lives and our
weekly shops and so on um and then the
issue of ni rises national insurance tax
rises to fund the nhs so there's a big
cost of living crisis on the way we've
got we've got the the grab of that so
let's say okay let's
exchange the reality is this
on top of the tory tax rises on top of
the soaring prices the lone shark
chancellor and his unwitting sidekick
have now picked up a buy now pay later
scheme
it leaves taxpayers in debt
while oil and gas companies say they've
got more money than they know what to do
with
it's the same old story with this
government get in a mess protect their
mates and ask working people to pick up
the bill
[Music]
[Applause]
but isn't he worried that everyone can
now see that with this prime minister
and this chancellor it's all one big
scam and people across the country are
paying a price
mr speaker what they can see is a
government that is absolutely committed
to doing the right thing for the people
of this country and taking the taking
the tough decisions when labour is
calling for us to take the easy way out
and spend more taxpayers money and this
is speaker it was it was this government
that decided to keep going in july uh
when he wanted uh to stay in lockdown we
kept going over christmas and new year
and by the way mr speaker it occurs to
me uh that we also were able to use
those brexit freedoms to deliver the
fastest things to work and the fastest
facts he wrote yes mr speaker when he
not only voted 48 times 48 times to go
back into the eu yes he did but he also
voted to stay in the european medicines
agency mr speaker
our plan our plan for jobs is working mr
speaker
we have record low youth unemployment
our plan for the nhs and care is working
mr speaker they have no plan at all mr
speaker our plan for the country is
working we have a great vision mr
speaker to unite and level up across our
country they have no plan
whatever mr speaker and i say to him
plan beats no plan we have a great plan
for our country they play politics
[Applause]
and you saw there jane the prime
minister tried to bat it away going back
to some of his you know greatest hits so
he sort of reiterated that he got it
right uncovered as he would argue he
talked about brexit there's a couple of
things in that
one is that the government's policy is
to give us all 200 pounds back in
october but as you know you then have to
pay it back in your bill over
uh the next four years which is the idea
of it just being
alone rishi sunak when he announced his
policy last week himself himself to our
economics editor ed conway said
this is going to bills are going to keep
on rising we can help you adjust to rise
in energy prices but this problem isn't
going away so the prime minister can try
and bat it off but it is staying and
what was interesting was someone on his
own back benches jeffrey clifton brown a
senior backbencher said well you don't
want to do a windfall tax on the oil and
gas companies but why can't you go and
try and get them to release more
supplies so the disquiet isn't about the
labour-backed benches there's worry on
the conservative benches because it
really hits their constituents
also interesting at the very beginning
of prime minister's questions boris
johnson made an announcement about uh
covert he wants to end the
self-isolation in covert cases a month
early
he told the commons that plans to remove
all remaining coronavirus restrictions
earlier than intended once parliament
returns from recess on the 21st of
february we've got that clip oh great
provided the current encouraging trends
in the data continue
it is my expectation that we will be
able to end the last domestic
restrictions including the legal
requirement to self-isolate if you test
positive a full month early mr speaker
did we see this coming well uh you can
see the cheers in the chamber i mean you
know that boris johnson has come under a
lot of fire from his own backbenchers
who hate the coved restrictions that is
clearly part of the boris johnson reset
to say i'm going to do it a month early
and you saw the cheer in the chamber on
that okay beth great stuff thanks very
much for that well before prime
minister's questions we spoke to our
people's panel voters unhappy with how
the government has addressed the issues
that really affect their lives let's go
back to them and see what they thought
about what they heard we're rejoined
from cheshire by craig russell his
daughter kelly smith died of bowel
cancer in june 2020 at the age of 31
after her chemotherapy was paused
because of chronovirus he's now set up a
group called catch up with cancer to
support those waiting for nhs treatment
we're also joined by susan hale she owns
and runs a coffee shop and tapas bar and
works
sop in nottinghamshire and has had to
reinvent her business to survive owns a
brewery as well and from blackpool
joined again by larry williams a single
parent on universal credit
at craig back to you first of all we
spoke to you before about the nhs how
important it is to you and and many
people your wife works in it you very
sadly lost your daughter boris johnson
to a question um from the snp leader in
the commons said that there would be
more nurses under this government um and
also that the national insurance hike is
necessary in order to pay and to help
clear the nhs backlog um
does that give you any any cause for
hope
frankly no
from what i heard
nothing in pmq's came as a great
surprise it really does
perhaps the only surprise i had is when
the prime minister said they have a plan
and it's working well i think it's news
to a lot of people in this country that
there even is a plan
but certainly from the point of view the
nhs the plans that are laid out at the
moment
having seen what the secretary of state
for health proposed yesterday as a
recovery plan
uh to me that's not a plan that's a wish
list that's the kind of thing an
eight-year-old would write to santa
about it's not a plan because
fundamentally it misses
most of the key objectives that are
needed so for example the institute of
public policy research did some research
into the backlog and they said that
if we were running at 105
capacity of pre-pandemic levels it would
take till 2033 to clear the backlog
yet somehow the government think they
can do that in two years
and that is before they get to capacity
so if again for me they may feel they
have a plan but for me it's completely
unrealistic and once again there was an
opportunity here
for correct planning to be put in place
to help people
get the correct treatment they need
through the nhs and it's yet again an
opportunity that's been missed
okay um susan susan hale uh you you
talked a little bit earlier about the
furlough scheme and how you were able to
get some help for one of your businesses
but not the other um
we saw questions to the prime minister
about the dismissal of fraud of course
there were a lot of people who took
those loans
um fraudulently and and those loans are
being written off how do you feel about
that given that you obviously stuck to
the rules and were only able to claim
for one of your businesses not both
makes you quite angry doesn't it
you know
we always knew there was going to be an
opportunity for forsters and things
should have been put in place to stop
that from happening and then when you
hear about millions of pounds being
written off yet here i am paying my
taxes and everything else if i don't pay
my taxes i get chased
therefore why would wiping all that
millions of pounds of money off that
could really go towards helping
businesses helping the nhs and maybe
going towards a fuel crisis that they
just keep batting off nobody is seems to
be coming up with straight answers a lot
of what i heard today was similar to
what i heard last week at prime
minister's question time we seem to be
going round in circles
the rate of inflation is going to go up
but i've been looking at this since
october last year
i am now looking at altering the prices
in my businesses by 11 12
to counteract the potential inflation
rate if it does reach them levels what
they are saying then a recession will
happen and nobody is willing to come to
the table and talk about what's going to
be happening in the future months what
backup plan they've got to counteract it
and what help is there going to be for
businesses who are fighting every day
with these rising fuel costs and then
you hear a shell and the profits that
they made why aren't we going after
these big companies who make millions
and billions of pounds that are
affecting the small people like me
again nothing was answered for me in
them questions today
larry you're nodding your head to that
you you're you're a single mom you
you're struggling financially um
the um the opposition leader kissed
armor made quite a lot of the
um the new scheme for electricity bills
calling the chancellor the loan shark
chancellor talking about a buy now pay
later
loan scheme how do you view
what's being offered in in terms of help
to meet energy bills over the coming
months
i actually think it's a joke i mean i
actually just put some figures down on
paper when them and they were mentioning
the 150 pound off council tax that's
12.50 per person a month on a monthly
payment you know what let's all just run
out and uh let's celebrate that we've
got 12 pounds to spend but we don't
really have 12 pounds when do we just
going back to council taxes or going in
taxes somewhere um there's just not
it's an absolute sham um
it you know i've actually just come to
conclusion he's full of fluff and air
and he's not answering any questions
again we need action and we need action
now and it needs to happen very very
quickly um there's going to be a mess
because basically what will happen is
the parents and people like me who don't
have any extra won't be able to pay
these bills we'll end up in a massive
massive areas on our accounts to the
point where we won't be able to pay it
we don't have any extra to pay it and
what will they do well they cut us off
and we'll end up with no supply you know
this is this is major for families the
old the elderly and pensioners people
like that you know they're already
sitting in cold houses because they
don't put the heating on and thank god
we've not had a
um you know a very cold winter but it
needs addressing now not in a few months
time and and quite rightly you know like
um we just said now that you know we
shall and all these companies are making
massive amount of profits
should be giving something back
okay well listen thank you all so much
really great to get your thoughts and
and hear what was important to you and
get your reactions to it as well
afterwards craig russell susan hale and
larry williams thank you all very much
for your time um well that is it for sky
news today uh for this hour but coming
up next lots more political reaction to
what has been going on in the houses of
parliament and more on that announcement
from the prime minister that he's going
to lift england's final covert
restrictions a month early what does
that mean for you what are the dates we
will bring you all the details after
this short break
[Music]
you never know what it's like to be on
an island and have the mediterranean all
to yourselves
you never know how comfortable it can
get to be away from home
you never know where the history of the
mediterranean was written
and once you know
you'll never forget
north cyprus
alice thought she'd save some money on a
smart exercise bike
thankfully she didn't penny pinch on her
broadband because she knows that with
bt's super fast fiber she gets
guaranteed speeds super strong wi-fi
from our smart hub with a which best buy
and all the security she could ever want
at 27.99 a month
she knows it's worth every penny
join bt today
[Music]
no more waiting for the kettle to boil
no more waiting for a pan of water to
boil with a cooker in your home you
always have instant 100 degrees boiling
water on demand
add the cube and you'll also have
chilled and sparkling water all from one
single tap
if you wish to understand how a cooker
works and explore the full range you can
book a live virtual one-on-one
appointment with one of our cooker team
this is a unique experience where you
control the meeting and what you would
like to see
we can explain how a cooker could help
you to save time energy water money and
even makes a kitchen a safer place
100 degrees boiling hot
cold filter chilled and sparkling water
the tab that does it all cooker
go to cooker.cod.uk and book your
virtual appointment now
there's a box called all around the ring
you got school it's been simmering i
know you didn't steal those watching
talking a big game you are getting it
next bike and
simmering who's gonna win the fight amir
khan is a conrad
sky sports box office
[Music]
this is sky news today it's one o'clock
these are our headlines
an end to self-isolation within weeks
the prime minister's strategy for living
with covert is going to be outlined to
mps
it is my expectation that we will be
able to end the last domestic
restrictions including the legal
requirement to self-isolate if you test
positive a full month early
the prime minister challenged over the
cost of living as rishi sunak is
described as a lone shark chancellor
who's left taxpayers in debt
also coming up
powered like the sun the energy
generation breakthrough that could pave
the way to limitless energy
the west ham football are booed by fans
and under police investigations for
kicking his cat
the secret sites operated by china to
detain uiga muslims and critics abroad
we'll have a special report
[Music]
and ballads over bangers adele is the
runaway winner of the brit awards
dominated by female artists
[Music]
hello good afternoon we start with
breaking news and the prime minister has
announced that he wants to end
self-isolation for coronavirus cases a
month earlier than previously announced
boris johnson told the comments he plans
to remove all remaining coronavirus
restrictions earlier than intended once
parliament returns from recess on the
21st of february
provided the current encouraging trends
in the data continue
it is my expectation that we will be
able to end the last domestic
restrictions including the legal
requirement to self-isolate if you test
positive a full month early mr speaker
well our correspondent laura bundock
joins us now live from the newsroom so
laura just clarify for us what does this
exactly mean when will restrictions end
and what restrictions will they be
yeah it's a really good question
actually because it may well feel to
many of us that all restrictions have
gone and indeed most of them have
because we were moved back into the
so-called plan a situation back on the
27th of january so that basically meant
no more working from home no more
compulsory face masks indoors and no
more covered passports inside many
indoor venues now the one thing that
remained was this self-isolation so if
you test positive the need to
self-isolate and that's the last thing
which seems that will finally be taken
away and that will be made at an